[Music]
our basel miami is back the annual art
exhibition was canceled last year due to
the pandemic but it's in full swing this
weekend as collectors and critics look
to the next generation of emerging
artists one making a name for themselves
is kennedy yanko artist in residence at
the rubell museum and as we saw for
ourselves the work is larger than life
an artist's studio is akin to one's home
it's private
intimate and there's always house rules
sculptor kennedy yanko let our cameras
into her brooklyn studio under the
condition we didn't share any of her
secrets i'm just trying to figure out
how you connected it all is so cool good
luck
that's what i just figured out this year
you're not going to tell me no wait
her craft has evolved through her desire
to marry paint with metal
i'm really interested in challenging
perception when you look at it you don't
know if it's light or heavy or soft or
hard and as soon as you understand it
then your whole mind is flipped upside
down on its head what makes it
unique
the process i think for me you know so
much of what i'm doing is it's really
responsive a process that requires all
of her strength and patience
does it always come out the way you
expect never
i was sitting here i was expecting
something totally different for this
piece really what were you expecting
well i mean it was supposed to go in
this way and go around and work this way
born in saint louis missouri yanko grew
up in a loving home with family who
always supported her creativity her
father took her to art classes at a
young age that was how he and i
connected in a lot of ways you know he's
a painter and a colorist and that was
always just a conversation that we would
both light up about early in her process
yanko figured out how to take paint off
of canvas and turn it into a
three-dimensional material a paint skin
this piece was
after i first started working with the
skins i started using uh
this like
rubber and i would take the rubber i
would roll it out and then i would throw
the paint in the air so the paint would
atom bomb and then i would take my body
underneath the rubber and i'd kind of
expand on the way that the fractal
details interact with itself she left
home at the age of 18 first to attend
the san francisco art institute then to
participate in the living theater in new
york city they would have writers and
and actors and painters and all
different minds come together in this
space where
we could all interact and talk in
different ways that's where i started to
learn about philosophy and psychology
and what it means as an artist to
conjure emotion within and to have it
come out
and that it has to come from here first
her curiosity led her to an
apprenticeship in metal welding and the
skill sets she needed for her next
chapter people look at metal as a
man-made industrial material when i
re-contextualize it visually or in my
mind there's a sense of imbuing it with
life just just through what i'm thinking
last year during the pandemic yanko
became the first sculptor to ever earn a
residency at the rubell museum
what it was don and mara rubell own one
of the largest contemporary art
collections in the world what did you
see in her
oh my god first magic magic
we power power we literally saw one
piece and it was just so moving and you
felt the power you felt the beauty of
being able to take ordinary ugly objects
and make them beautiful and you also
felt something which you almost never
feel the ability to make a gigantic
sculpture
the opportunity gave her the tools and
space she needed to begin creating the
work she dreamed of i used over 100
gallons of paint for the skins there
because i had a room where i could do my
skins like do 40 feet of skins it was
like lay faltering for me because this
is a material that i worked with for 12
years and i'm just now beginning to
really understand it
this is the result
it's called white passing
i think making this work
was a self analysis
it is about a kind of skin what it means
to shed skin what it means to change
colors of skin
my work has is always pulled into
conversations around gender and
sexuality and identity and i haven't
addressed my racial
existence before
until she started writing the graphic
novel
indelible fluidity when i first started
writing it i had to look at my face
and i had to look at my skin and my body
in a way that i was never
forced to do before and i really had to
understand what my existence and what my
contribution to the world is as an
artist and as a person you really can't
make serious art if you're not dealing
with truth within yourself her latest
work has captured the attention of
renowned abstract artist leonardo drew
her mentor she needed to deal with these
things you know there's otherwise her
work would not have actually
transitioned to where it is right now i
don't think there is anything more
special than finding your voice is there
a destination or like your art
are you allowing life to move you in
whatever direction
you end up in i have very ambitious
projects i want to take on
um
i don't know how that's going to happen
or where or when but i trust that it
will i want to make really big
huge architectural
sculptures
like when you say big huge what do you
mean like building size
building sun yeah
building size well that blue sculpture
we saw kennedy make is for a show she's
doing next spring with cf hill in
stockholm the piece will be featured
with 19th century abstract artist hilma
off clint sound familiar when anthony
mason was doing his piece she's last
week last week right when he did that
piece he exposed us to the fact that she
may have been
the very first abstract artist on the
books but
just an incredible artist yanko is
kennedy
her first name she's incredible i loved
this was towards the end of the piece
but without having your own truth you
can't create the art that she is
creating what would it you know that's
for so many things out
there your life right and just the
notion of taking or they talked about
these pieces right taking ordinary
objects and turning them into something
sublime recycling how about that
recycling
by the way the fashion in it the two of
you phenomenal absolutely phenomenal